et vous
[Musique]
bon vous
pièce est l'histoire d'un mec père
connaissait le post il parle aussi bon
j'ai des fois c'est déposée par un peu
[Musique]
juste l'ardéchoise
reconnaissez-le au nom du club et quand
les gens la connaissent ça prend mais
l'air d'un con parce que y est par
exemple assez bon je veux dire c'est vie
mais il y a
j'hésite parce que des fois c'est
l'histoire lors barbier bagnols à la
rebaptise il ya paris le bourget diriez
ou alors des fois c'est l'histoire et
plusieurs mecs tous armés d'une heure et
sa gueule mais qu'ils ou alors des fois
dans l'est mais là non non là c'est
l'histoire d'un mec mais on n'y avait
pas non
un nom mais julien n'est pas un jeu un
mec normal que je dirais même un blanc
[Musique]
parce que par le passé battu par des
mecs des foyers bon je devais y aller
par exemple aider mais ça dépend des
mecs parce que sous les cieux même mais
dans la passion de genre le mec aussi
aller vite
oui oui oui mais non alors leur dit mais
quand même des fois on est bien obligé
nono et là c'est plutôt avec nos mecs
mais normal je dire pas lui
ah oui non passionnant parce je ne
voulais pas séparable de genre
d'histoires aussi away alors passez pas
mes histoires c'est plus rigolo quand
c'est un juif
si on n'est pas un juif un abbaoui fois
minimum et puis par les histoires c'est
plus rigolo grâce et un belge
si on est suisse ouais puis le contraire
si la suisse car et belge badger belges
et suisses et deux seules races se
rendent pas compte qu'en fait c'est
pareil mais c'est normal parce qu'à
cause de la distance qui les sépare
alors ils disent tu pars de bahreïn et
chose mais je vous jure ce mot mais non
comme une différence gérable et par
l'énorme enfin quand même mais tomba
l'on peut rencontrer
vrai qu en suisse c'est un âge mais
l'ensemble ça va être un coup de fer
deux pays rien que pour ça en plus de
murets
enfin moi je dis ça je m'en fous un jeu
fini belle je dis juste les juifs art
suis normal alain mais que normal aussi
lui mais si on préfère que ça soit
ensuite je m'en fous moi je prends mon
dieu et tourne
non je dis il ya quand même et quand
même moins d'étrangers que de raciste en
france
alors non je dire si j'ai le choix nous
sommes engueulés avec les moins
nombreuses fois bon alors un suisse
wuala ans ou monde heureusement non en
tout cas c'est pas un noir la main
d'abord passé ya aucune raison pour que
ça soit toujours les mêmes qui dérouille
et puis deuxièmement si c'est un noir
c'est facile
un noir parce qu en fait j'en suis donc
besoin d'un noir aimé les noirs mais
qu'il dit je dire de me disent les
on les appelle comme ça exprès ou
d'ailleurs oui mais le font pas des
chats morts la plupart passé sur et nous
ne passions du eux tous aller qui suit
bon mais j'ai en fait c'est nul je veux
dire s'est démené tout petit déjà fait
des fois même leurs parents
oui pas tous mais enfin plupart domaine
alors alors là le mec non la lui normal
attendant ses enfants je vous dirai
jamais que tous appelaient à un mec bon
oui passionnant se bâtit aussi quand
même bâchée l'histoire avis déjà que les
gens restent assez beau non parce que
c'est un bon d'accord mais c'est un mec
qui est sur le pont de l'alma which away
et c'est un métier support l'alma bon
d'accord si on veut mais c'est un métier
sur le pont de l'alma et qui regarde
dans l'eau de match par contre
ah ouais parce que moi je ne croyais pas
j'étais voir ben c'est vrai
à lui que ce pont de l'alma rien même
pas la tablette adam et hip hop tous les
jours ce pont alma et bien il n'y aurait
pas d'eau dessous il passera quand même
un genou ont pas sur les ponts en
contiennent au dessous ne touchez pas au
prince tout penaud il regarde alors là
le mec qui regarde l'histoire
elle me dit regarde tous à part ça
intéresse tous ah bon au bout d'une
demi-heure passée normalement l'histoire
a duré une demi-heure mais moi
j'aimerais je ne serais pas allé au bout
d'une demi-heure il ya un hôte mais
qu'arrive-t-il aux normales aussi nommé
blanc il arrive et artistes qui voit le
pays voit mais qu'est l'hadopi le
meilleur du nokia d'oulu pas déconner
alors monsieur lui jugé un peu plus
premier dilemme et yaël pascal ya leur
lit parce qu'il ya deux mecs maintenant
non prenez des notes impasse je vais pas
répéter gens suivaient merde je m'en
fous moi je la colère
c'est vraiment pour rendre service à la
mecque noms suivent et voilà à presque
en voudrait la raconter aux arts a l'air
de bessines alors bon alors le mec alors
patienter vous alors il sa place tu y as
parce que le mec bon attend à larissa
france chili malade et aurait que la
libye et tué ou fait à regarder dans
l'eau oui le make our suisse au chili
ah ben je suis amer des passagers c'est
tomber mes lunettes dans la loire
monsieur pont de l'alma c'est sur la
scène
ah ça je ne sais pas on comprend que
dalle correspondront la csn alors
justement c'est pourtant à rebecq
passionnante du jeu tombé dans la loire
faut quand même apprendre les suisses
que pour des cons non il ya des belles
jantes en alu eux c'est fini
mais déjà comme ça et me rend très
actifs alors alors alors philippe
pasquier qui 10 $ l'unité pas la rentrée
j'aime me dire si vous aviez à l'eau
alors l'aube du coup à la fin de ce
mécanisme à l'un des rares dix au bout
ça et moi sans les lunettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]